okay man heute ja ich merke sie maria
weiss ich warum wurden der
bachmann-preis beginnt ich liebe ihn was
ist der bachmann-preis ein wettlesen in
klagenfurt für mich ist das das schönste
ereignis um ja auch mein gott schöner
ist nicht zutreffen online
philipp war auch schon in klage jahr
zwar nicht stiller beobachter sondern
stellt guten tag meine damen und herren
ich freue mich sehr dass ich heute hier
sein kann im prinzip ist es eine
fantastische idee dass man literatur
vorträgt und dann direkt im anschluss
die kritiker runde stattfindet es
langweilt auch ich habe den eindruck den
quelle katalog gibt es jetzt kommentiert
es ist eine kaum von entertainment
wenn man da vorne sitzt da setzt man
sich ja schon auch ganz schön aus oder
nein ich ganz ehrlich wer sich ins
literatur geschäft begibt der muss
einstecken können in dieser text ist
überflüssig ich will gar nicht sagen
dass das mich das kalt gelassen hat ganz
im gegenteil
aber ich halte mir zugute dass ich
einigermaßen einstecken kann also ich
hab dich sozusagen nur aus thailand
erlebt was mich an dem preisschub ist
das konzept von literatur was dahinter
steht und zwar ist es ein konzept was
ich für überlebt hat ich habe mir
gedanken gemacht was zeichnet eigentlich
einen stil aus der gute chancen hätte
sich durchzusetzen ich habe sechs
kriterien mitgebracht ich würde jetzt
spontan sagen vier davon sollten erfüllt
sein damit wir von bachmann preis pro
sprechen können
pseudo autobiografischer beziehung viele
texte haben einen autobiografischen
bezug und wenn nicola viele sagt meinen
sie
nein das stimmt nicht wenn man sich die
neuerscheinungen der literatur anschaut
kommt er ja sowieso immer wieder vor
meyerhoff klaus ja okay wie vor ich mir
wieder anhören muss wie großartig hat
meyerhoff ist mache ich gerne mit dem
zweiten kriterium weiter drittes reich
oder deutsche geschichte da habe ich gar
nicht geredet hast du hier nicht so
aktiv unterstützt aber du hast recht ich
werde mich gerne erweitern seit 1989
wird dieses nazi motiv auch gerne
abgelöst oder idealerweise natürlich an
die seite gestellt von deutsch deutsch
ich erzählerin wieso in es wird auf
jeden fall gerne in der ersten person
geschrieben besonders gern von den
weiblichen kandidatinnen keine
qualifizierte aussage ich mache in
diesem text die bekanntschaft mit einem
ich erzähler der ganz offensichtlich
qualen pubertät noch nicht ganz in tron
ist stil der para taktischen reihung das
stimmt es handelt sich um hauptsätze
gerne auch seitenweise verbunden nur mit
und nehmen das stimmt gar nicht was das
alles stimmt gar nicht
es gab auch sehr komplizierte texte okay
ich habe ja gesagt von den sechs
kriterien müssen nur 4 erfüllt sein
damit wir von bachmann preis browser
sprechen okay manchmal weiter ich mache
weiter mit leitmotiv realisierung der
identität und identität das ist mein
zeichen für und du musst das in
verbindung sehen mit diesem wichtigen
punkt hier ja mit den augen
esoterische innerlichkeit es geht
nämlich immer um eine marginalisierung
wo sonst keiner zugang hat das war alles
vielen dank